bonjour et 2 tricoteuses de plus à
l'atelier europe loisirs à tours nord
pour réaliser des poches en tricot pour
les bébés marsupiaux sauver des
incendies gigantesques en australie pour
les dames qui ne viennent d'arriver
on fait des petits pochon en tricot ou
crochets celle qu'ils préfèrent
il y à deux dimensions 18 sur 20 et 24
sur 30 en rangs serrés la quinzaine de
tricoteuses s'activent pour tricoter des
poches pour les kangourous et koala
orphelins c'est grâce à facebook et un
poste des ch'tis pochon pour l'australie
que catherine a décidé d'agir
j'ai vu ça sur internet une amitié sur
facebook
il faisait ça et pour faire été
sensibilisés par ces pauvres petits
animaux
je les ai contactés et el mahdi ben ok
tu peux lancer le projet sur l'indre et
loire depuis des tricoteuses de toute la
touraine de bourgueil à saint cyr ou
contactez catherine pour proposer leur
aide et coudre de leur côté des sacs en
tissu amovible pour l'hygiène et
tricoter des pochons les images des
marsupiaux en détresse ont été lus et
sensibiliser de nombreuses associations
comme la maison de la solidarité à
tours-nord le mardi après-midi anti du
hanap à coudre oui les poches pour les
kangourous mais qu'on va envoyer nouveau
parc animalier de carcassonne d'accord
on va rajouter les poches
pour m le but vide voilà d'accord pas de
problème dès que parent je pensais que
c'était plus pour les congo j'aurais pas
penser qu'elle koala l'est aussi dans
les poches et après j'ai vu un reportage
comme quoi illimitée dans les poches
il est suspendu puissants comme s'ils
étaient être leur maman catherine
récoltera les pochons jusqu'au 11
février date du dernier atelier on a de
la chance une dame a vu l'article dans
le journal et part en australie mi
février donc on a la chance elle va nous
emmener 10 à 15 c laude pochon un peu de
répit pour les tricoteuses qui auront
fabriqué d'ici là des centaines de
pochon pour les bébé koala et kangourou
orphelins